HOW 'S DEFINED DEPENDSRE AND MOU
NOW
,
REPUBLICANOVOEM  SOUTHA, ABORTI
JOINING ME THIS MORNIN IS A VER
LOD
I WANTO SPEND SOME TE
AMERICA. RSTAND SOME OF THE MAN
AND I WANT TO START WITH  HEARD
FEW  WHICH IS, YOUING TOGSIDE MH
DECIONNT TO ASK YOU ATOKS LIKE.
PAI FOR EXAMPLE
PARENT L STATE-FUNDED
CHILD CARE MOTRSK
CA THEIR
>>ILY AVLICY I
SOMETHING THAT I ADDRESSED AS
ER
DAKOTA.
NKS IMPORTANT WE
PLE WHEN THEY
NNEDR INTO A WHERE
MANYL  THEY HAVE ANCY THAT'S NO
I LAUNCH A THAMAPS WITH
MEDICAL NANCIAL
NNECTS THIS EM TO
PARENT TIRF THATE TO
CHOICE THEMAKE.  GOVERNOR, I WEI
INGOOU T
ON THEN Y
COMES IN IDAKOTER ACCESS
FINANCIALLY TO CHILD CARE?
>> THAT'S A DISCUSSIE' HAVE.
STRONGER FAMILIES.TANT ECTI'M S
IMPORTANT F
CHILDRE WITH THEM.
TO A PRIORITY FOR
OUR STATE.'S INTERTIOUTH
S IT'SLEGI
WE G FATORS.
LS FBILLS.
WEEB HAVSESSION.D WEEFM THE LE
HE
SUPPORT.
>> IT'S A VERY
YNAMIC
YOU HAVE A PRETTY POWERFUL
PUWHAT'S YR LY LEAVE.
LLUSH FOR ?
IN THE PASAND TALKED AUTVING THH
NSLICY LIKE SEL
ATAND THAT'S A THANY TIME FINANA
THA PEOPLE
HAVE AOU TIME SUPPORTING,
BUT I INK IN SOUTH DAKOTA THATT
LOW INCOME WOMEN SOUTH DAKOTTHOR
RI AN AF  EXPANDED
E.G BALLOTDAKOTA IN
NOVEMBER.
WILL YOUUP THAT?
SURE THAT  EXPANSION D COVER AB
INT ALSO WOULDNCLUDE
ABOUT ANT TO
STATE.
BLOTHATIL
I'LL CTAT'S
IMPLEMENTED FAIR DONE
FAIRLY.
ITHING THAT I
CONTINUE TO LOT TO THETA
INCRIBT IT COVERS
ARE PEOPLE THAE SI AABLE BODIEDB
N VERY FEW
OPRE
UNEMPLOYMENT RIGHT NOW.
>> OUR IOM UFASTER HE OTA THAN
EC BETTER, EN THOUGH WE'RRE WFLF
THE BIDE'SHAPPENWI.C.
>> REAL QUICK, IT'S ON THE
U'SLY.
WILL Y VE ?EPT BE VOTINR MYY BEE
TAINCREASEOUPPEN TR ITSE PEOPLEY
CERTAINLY PLONED YWEBSITE. OTHR
ORI'M JUST TRYING TO UAND,
YOLEAVE.
WHAT ELSE WILL YOU
FO IAND, YOU HAVE TODO IT IN PA
LESL IS ING ABORSIBILITY TO
CTLY SUPPORT, FINANCY
H SERVICES
RLS, CHILDREN?
>> WELL, WE H MANY
URS ALREAD AND YL  THAT?
>> MY
DO .
YES, I DO BE
TOIS TOLD RLY THAT'S AEB WHAE CA
ATMA CENTERS
OSE THK Y BRINGING
IDEAS ANWE'LDIDE I20S
PASSAY SUPREME
OVERTURNING ROE CKAT T THE LENN
NOW THAT THAT'S THLAW, W WHO ISE
LAW, IPUNISHED, THAT'SORS, NOT T
OPHENONISHED IN
ME ASK U ABOUT .DI
DAYS PREGNANT NOL N IX
ACROES TO INDIANA TO
RECEIVE  A
THAT WAS
BEANYO
T OKOTA
D FORCA
10-YEAR-OLD IN THASITUATION TO
THATED A 10-YEAR-OLD.DIBLE IS NU
WH ATHAT>> I AGREE WIT
ISSUE THAT THE SUPREME COURT HA
>> I TOTALLY WANTE
>> WHA C
LITTLE GIR
WE ALSO NE TO  ADDRESSING
THOSE SICK INDIVIDUALS TT DO
THO ENN'T  BUT OUR
IES AND WOMEN
ARE THT.
, ITASWOMAN.
LDHE HAVE TO HAVE -- A CHILD
VERY SINGLLIFE IS
US.
THRA.MAGINEER HADNY
FAMILY OR MYSELF GONE THROUGH
AN
ILLEGAL CEHEIFMAGIT IN D LAW THR
10-YEAR-OLD GIG TO HAVE Y WITA
A BA NO,EVER O
THAT STORY WILUP
GHEAYOU CHANGE THE LAWO VEN R AT
>> A MHER HAD
GRANAU
T EVENMAD SAY I DON'LIUATIONHO
PEUA TRADYE'
MAKEE  AREG A LIFEAY EVERY LIFIS
ESPECIALLY INNOCENT LIVES THAT
HAVE BEERET
S INCREDLYITBUT GU QUESTIOGIVENO
E ION, MAYBETION IS THISBECAUSAR
MI MIND EMOTIOY AND
PHYSALD YOU CONSIDER THAMOTHER'S
LIFE AT  T THAT TUIOE E INDIVIDL
EVERY STATWIERENT RESTABTHE TIM
S DE
TO THE PEOPLE THAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
IT
FROM CEDI  STHRY
DIFFERENTH YORK'S WHERE
THAT GOVERNOR SAID SHE WANTS TO
BE A DESTINATION KNOWN FOR
E WILLAKE VERY R Y GOVERNOR
>> ON NOTE,PUS
NATIONAL BAN O KNOW, WE'LL SEE
NGAN
DISCUSSIONS ARE.N D PEOPLE WS
ARE, HOW I WOULD LEAI
WOULD FO THROUGH ON THAT
THAT'S SOMETHING I'VE ALYS
DONE RUNNING F ELECTREPRESENT YE
THATYOU HOND
YOE YOUR JOBS GOVERNOR.
WE TAW THAT DURING.
DECISIONS THAT WER IN
ENSTR LE'S FAMILIES D THR  MADED
I HA THIS TION IINN OUR FAMILIES
THEEY'RE CREATI.THURITGOIN
I' C NASTATITHIS
FIGHT TO DEFEND THE  IN
SOUTKOQUS IT STATE
>> IT'S A ION -- OR SHOULD IT ?
-SEXRRIAGEE REID. BMARRIAGE F20
THE
OUUPME
RECONSIDER THAT DECISION AS HIN
FR JUSTICE ALITO'S CME
WADE ANDD DID CA GOING
WIN ITN. RIGHT?RNTINUE THICI
EACH ISSUE WILL BE
I  S HAVE
ECISIONS ANDON
THAT'S WHAT'S ROUGY ABOUT
EA DECISIONS,
HAS DEBATE ON POLICYND
MY JOB AS TO MAKE
SURE THAT I'